let's jump on to the phones and see
what's on people's minds our number is
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty we will go to our caller
from the 608 area code caller tell us
who you are and what's on your mind
today
caller from 6:08 are you there hi David
this is Bryan from Madison Wisconsin
Bryan we were milliseconds from ending
the call but you showed up that's good
what's on your mind today
regarding yesterday's citizens testimony
and the broader scandals over the White
House do you think that Democrats are
putting too much political capital and
public energy into the investigation of
collusion between Russia and the Trump
campaign when some of the financial
scandals like that children's
not-for-profit or the are they
violations of the amount emoluments
clause through the Trump Organization
has just so much more evidence and are
potentially equally damning yes so
two-part answer very very good question
so number one there's a risk for
Democrats to just putting energy into
the Russia investigation instead of
other investigations into Trump because
as you're pointing out astutely there's
so much else that is disturbing
including the emoluments Clause
violations potentially including the non
profit and charitable donation issues
and and it really goes actually quite a
bit further than that but there's
another angle to this which is I've been
increasingly concerned and this applies
both to House and Senate Democrats but
also to a lot of the energy that's
behind many of the big protests we've
seen dating all the way back to November
of 2016 that just being anti Trump is
really really risky and progressives
need to have a platform that stands on
its own really for two reasons number
one if nothing comes of Trump Russia
other than just hampering Trump's PR for
the next two to four years then you're
going to need something other than being
about Trump Russia to justify people
voting for you in 2018 and 2020 but
think about it the other way as well if
Trump Russia leads to Trump being
impeached or resigned just
hypothetically thinking ahead
once Trump's gone you also can't just
run against Trump because Trump's gone
so I completely agree with you and I
would even go further than what you're
saying that yes there needs to be
focused in many other areas while these
investigations happen but it's important
to focus on and report on the
investigations as well yeah definitely
agree you know I do think that while
there were definitely in proprieties
within you know sessions recusing
himself and on firing come--and commis
testimony about you know Trump asking
for his loyalty that isn't direct
collusion with the Russians and this
whole thing might be a lot of wasted
effort
ultimately backfires on on the yeah I
mean there's certainly that risk and
that's why it's important to to focus on
more than just that thanks so much for
the call really really appreciate it